[MUSIC PLAYING]
HENG-TZE CHENG: Wide
and Deep learning
combines the power
of memorization
and generalization,
and it does that
by jointly training
widening your models
and deepening your networks.
We're sharing a
research paper about it
and also the implementation
with an easy-to-use API
in TensorFlow, which is an open
source library for a machine
intelligence.
So you might wonder what Wide
and Deep learning is good for.
Wide and Deep learning is
useful for generic large scale
regression and classification
problems with sparse inputs,
things like recommendation
systems, search,
and ranking problems.
Now imagine you wanted to
build a search engine for food.
Given a query, you want
to recommend the items
that your users
will like the most.
Using widening your
models, you can actually
use a wide set of cross-product
features transformations
to memorize specific
feature combinations.
An example would be
when the users say
the query, "fried
chicken," your model
might memorize that
chicken and waffles
is more relevant than
chicken fried rice.
But one limitation
is that it's actually
hard to generalize to
previously unseen combinations
without manual
feature engineering.
So instead, using
deep neuronetworks,
you can now generalize better
through lower dimension
embeddings.
For example, your model might
learn to recommend burgers
given the query, "fried
chicken," because they
are similar types of food.
However, sometimes memorizing
specific combinations
as rules and exceptions
is very important.
When people ask for
iced decaf latte,
you don't really want to
overgeneralize and give them
hot latte no matter
how close they
are in the embedding space.
So by jointly training
Wide and Deep models,
we actually allow
them to complement
each other's strengths
and weaknesses.
MUSTAFA IPSIR: To help
developers get started,
we released Wide and Deep
as part of the TF Learn API.
TF Learn is a high level
machine learning library
on top of TensorFlow.
The API helps users focus
on the important questions
like, how will you
design your features,
and what is your
model structure?
You can create a Wide
and Deep classifier
with just a few lines of code.
Then you specify
the features you
use in the widening model
and the deep neuronetworks,
and we handle the joint
training under the hood.
There are different
needs and requirements
from Deep learning networks
and Wide [INAUDIBLE] models.
We found a way to balance this.
We provide a simple feature
engineering interface
that lets you
specify embeddings,
crosses, and
bucketization easily.
For example, to learn
the relationship
between a specific query
and a specific item,
you can define across columns
with a single line of code.
Similarly, to learn
generalization,
you can define an
embedding column
with a single line of code.
HENG-TZE CHENG:
So to get started,
we encourage developers to
check out our blog posts
in the description, which links
to our tutorials, code samples,
and our research paper.
We really hope more
and more people
will find these
useful in their work
and explore the possibilities of
Wide and Deep Learning with us.